[Music]
i tried deep throating a banana once and
i got a boner from it
amazing holy [ __ ] there's a couple guys
on route on their regular jobs just
driving sweating it right now
[Laughter]
it's just funny to be to be tripping
about that yeah that's what's funny
obviously you're a yeah he's a 23 year
old guy yeah that's like am i gay i
don't know
he's as hard as he wrote it yeah exactly
i wrote a reddit post and i got hard
[Laughter]
do i want to [ __ ] reddit so i am a 23
year old man and i was eating a banana
once and i thought of deep throating
such a crazy thought
just for the sake of it yeah for sure
just for the sake of it yeah just for
the sake of seeing what girls feel or if
it's a hard task and it appears that it
got me hard doing that does that mean i
am gay does any of you guys tried it
does any of you guys tried it before
that's a crazy sentence has any of you
guys tried it before i'm sure that i'm
not alone in this right right
not saying that it's wrong being gay
edit a lot of the comments really helped
me understand things i just saw a
comment about people might trying to do
this and after they read the thread so
please do not try to do this the banana
can break you can choke to death
can you imagine you're like i almost
died and i got a boner from it
does that mean i'm like into death
that's actually dobrix new video
he almost died and was hard
[Laughter]
this is clearly like what the [ __ ] is
this click on it like yeah some dude
choking on a banana oh
full bone
[Applause]
what is it
uh please
please be safe thank you please be safe
thank you if you want to try please do
this with more sturdy stuff so funny to
like be eating a banana then go i wonder
if this is hard
he's an empath though yeah
you know he can like looking at that
banana he could sense women have a hard
time driving yeah yeah that's what it is
he's trying to connect with women yeah
yeah yeah he's a feminist too yeah
exactly yeah he's a he's trying to see
he's trying to see where they're coming
from he's trying to look at the world
through their eyes the wife comes home
and the dude is just [ __ ] ramming a
dildo down so i'm just trying to get in
too with your experience
[Laughter]
she like pulls it out she pulls out a
small butt plug she's like well it's a
little bit more like this
what the [ __ ] bro the comments on that
thread had me crying what are the
comments one of them was like you better
suck a real dick just to make sure
and then the fallout was like you should
probably suck two dicks just to be sure
and then they just kept going
yeah yeah whatever you got to do to get
your fruits and veggies
am i gay what's happening it's like
maybe just like deep throating bananas
you know what i mean you're somewhere
that's that's on the spectrum you know
he has a banana hanging out his mouth
he's hard as hell and crying
i don't understand
he calls his mom okay
okay okay
[Music]
look i'm hard this points the camera
down honey what the [ __ ] i'm at work i'm
warned and i think i'm gay so dude so
that one was good and then i i
screenshotted this one i've dubbed him
six pack guy that's so ridiculous man
most people wouldn't want to date a
shredded six-pack guy okay nice okay
hear me out three days ago i decided
enough was enough three years ago my bad
no three days let's change it i was like
damn
three years ago i decided enough was
enough i started my path to getting lean
and gain muscle i succeeded i have a
visible six-pack and i'm currently doing
a clean bulk my overall appearance is
it's it's a good thing
but oh it's it's good i think good i
think
that [ __ ] it's good i think
the thing is every time a girl is
interested in me will start today to
quickly start to get annoyed by the fact
that i'm extremely picky or selective
with my food i don't drink i don't need
trash food etc they think that i'm a
weirdo or something like that and i
don't blame them but how did you think i
got this physique just doing exercise
one girl once told me i spent too much
time in the gym also
obviously i'm not saying you should want
or accept my obsessive actions from so
sick of people like assuming you can get
my body with like going three days a
week to the gym
sorry if i misspelled anything that's
awesome
that's [ __ ] awesome
you know if hilarious though if this guy
was spending eight hours a day in the
gym and oh that's yeah and only eating
tuna yeah
tuna and like
grain rice that he develops himself in a
garden yeah it's like no you this is
weird dude yeah
you do spend too much time in the gym
yeah swiping on some girl on tinder and
they go meet up and maybe the girl just
you know it's never really worked out
before it's just not her thing she
doesn't really understand fitness you
want to get a drink and he's like [ __ ]
no yeah
you're trying to [ __ ] with my macros
yeah empty carbs sick date no thanks you
think i look like this by eating all
this [ __ ] trash food and drinking out
of your [ __ ] mind
okay
what do you do for work
i'm in the gym like 3-4 hours a day
wow that's a lot shut the [ __ ] up it's
not that much
how do you think i got a body like this
just by doing stupid little exercises i
know what you are you're one of those
girls that thinks i was a small little
puny [ __ ] before i just want to let you
know i had this body i've had this party
the whole time i've been this way okay
see this is you know what you need is
like a fitness girlfriend that's what
the top comment was yeah just be one of
the couples on instagram all they do is
go to the gym
that would make you happy instead
just going on dates on purpose with
girls that aren't really into fitness
what if what if he's not even that big
what if he's just like you know
it's buck 40
yeah he's like a slim jacked yeah yeah
yeah he's like he doesn't want [ __ ]
women dude he doesn't want to date the
the fitness girls because they're
[ __ ] more yolks than him
dude i was working out in omaha
i went to
under this gym [ __ ] dope ass gym
i was laughing because
every [ __ ] high schooler in there was
twice my size yeah and i went to the
show that night i'm like i worked out i
saw these high schoolers that were twice
my size i'm like i should just be at a
gun range i have no reason to practice
getting bigger well it's i think there
it's either
you get super jacked and go to the gym
all the time or you do heroin yeah i see
why guys get caught up in those states
yeah it's all white women and drugs
i was surprised at the you know the
sheer amount of just people yeah i think
that's how you get caught up in the
middle of some flat ass land and some
girls like you want to try perk 30 yeah
[ __ ] yeah where are you here from texas
you're not leaving why
oh
she just never tried liquid morphine
what you're had liquid morphine while
having sex
no i've never oh oh
[ __ ]
almost sure
oh miss you
yeah there's another one but it's not
that good especially this guy he's like
i confess to my wife i have a fetish and
his fetish is he likes to wear designer
underwear
that's a sick ass fetish like he likes
calvin klein boxers
that's not a fetish yeah all the
comments were like um damn i got a
fetish for dripping too hard
now you know he grew up in like some
repressed ass household yeah exactly
yeah
i just i just i was raised wearing fruit
of the looms yeah
you know that's why
what i wore to church every sunday
through the looms and so to me that's
like a godly pair of underwear you know
my dad he would he only ever bought me
underwear in bulk
top of the year you know i got 50 pairs
for the year and that was it i hated the
way they felt chafed my balls it was
awful and when i grew up i was like i'm
gonna buy nice underwear
and now it just makes me feel so dirty
yeah
but like in a good way
imagine him going to the [ __ ]
confession booth forgive me father for
i've sinned what are your sins son i got
a pair of [ __ ] versace boxers on
right now let me see oh you want to see
him yeah i want to see yeah here i'll
show you the waistband
oh yeah there's a little speaker there's
a little peak of the waistline
what
what
i mean what else do you want to see it's
just fabric let me see the bottom
turn around oh no
come on that's not my fetish but it's
mine
he comes out to his wife as gay because
he likes nice underwear yeah yeah i put
on a pair of nice boxers the other day
and i got a boner
am i gay
honey i think i'm gay
put on calvin klein boxers and i got
hard i deep-throated a pair of my
underwear
i was hard and i looked at the guy on
the package and he was hard
i think i'm gay what
i was hard
yeah i had a boner and i accidentally
saw a guy
i'm thinking it works the other way
around
i don't know i had a no reason boner for
some reason on the train and i looked at
a guy am i gay okay
you